[موسيقى]
منطقه البحر الاسود شهدت تطورات عده منذ
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا كما تحولت ايضا
لساحه قتال بحري استخدمتها روسيا في
عملياتها الهجوميه ضد كياف وكذلك لفرد
حصار على الموانئ الاوكرانيا المواجهات
التي شهدها البحر الاسود زادت من قلق
الدول المطله على هذا البحر والتي معظمها
من اعضاء حلف النيتو لكن السؤال ما تاثير
هذا التمركز الروسي على خطط الحلف وكذلك
ايضا تاثر برامج التسلح لهذه الدول وان
الملاحه في البحر الاسود حول هذا الموضوع
معنى الدكتوره اللواء جوجها المسؤوله
السابقه في حلف انيته واستاذ الدراسات
الامن الاوروبي في جامعه جورج تاون في
واشنطن اولا الدكتور يوريا اهلا بك معنا
في عسكريه الى اي مدى همم الحرب في
اوكرانيا زادت من عسكرت منطقه البحر
الاسود وكذلك هل تاثرت برامج التسلح لدول
هذه المنطقه ام لها
شكرا لكم على هذه الاستضافه صحيح لقد
شهدنا ان منطقه البحر الاسود وعلى مدى
سنوات طويله لا سيما بعد عام 2008 مع غزو
روسيا لجورجيا وخاصه منذ عام 2014 اسر
الغزو الروسي الاول لاوكرانيا قد شهدت
عسكره متزايده رئيس رومانيا السابق
والرئيس التركي الحاليد ابا على تسميه
البحر الاسود بالبحيره الروسيه في ظل
عسكرته من قبل روسيا وهو امر كانت له
تداعيات على حلف الناتو واراضي دول
الاعضاء المطله على البحر الاسود وسط نشري
روسيا اسلحه بعيده المدى لا سيما في شبه
جزيره القرم وهو ما اضحى يشكل تهديدا
مباشره
في رابع عسكريا بحري ولم يقدم الناتو على
زياده تسلحه بسبب عسكره روسيا للبحر
الاسود
وبسبب غزو روسيا واسع اوكرانيا في عام
2022 عمدا نيته الى اتخاذ تدابير من خلال
نشر قوات بريه وليست بحريه لردع روسيا على
امتداد سواحل البحر الاسود وداخل اراضي
اعضائه لا سيما في رومانيا وبلغاريا اما
بالنسبه للمجال البحري فاننا لم نرميته
يتخذ اي اجراءات من شانها ردع روسيا
عسكريا الامر الوحيد الذي نلاحظه حاليا
وهو لا صلط له بالنيته وانما يتعلق ببلد
عضو فيه وهو تركيه هو انه خلال الساعات
الاربع والعشرين او الثمانيه والاربعين
الماضيه قامت تركيه بكسر الحصار الذي
فرضته روسيا على تسطير الحبوب الى العالم
حيث اشاهدنا الكثيره من سفن الشحن تعبر
البحر الاسود بمرافقه عسكريه وهي اول
اشاره يبعث بها ليس ناتو وانما بلد عضو
فيه
عائله ردعي روسيا عن عسكره البحر الاسود
دكتوره لوليا هذا الحديث يشير الى انه
روسيا اصبحت تفرض نفسها كقوه عسكريه بحريه
مهيمنه على البحر الاسود بالكامل واذا صح
هذا الحديث هل تعتقد بانه هذا الامر ايضا
كشف عن اي نقاط قصور في القوات البحريه
الروسيه في هذه المنطقه وفي
سينما
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه وكذلك ابان
الحرب الدائره في عام 2022 ان اوكرانيا
نجحت في مهاجمه الاسطول الروسي في البحر
الاسود حيث تعرضت سفن روسيه للهجوم من قبل
اوكرانيا وليس الناتو وقد شاهدنا تداعيات
ذلك على البحر الاسود والعالم كله كما انه
وجودها في بحار العالم عسكريا قد تراجع
تشير تقارير الى عزم روسيا خفضه وجودها
العسكري في البحر الابيض المتوسط بسبب
الخسائر التي تكب في البحر الاسود هل
سيتواصل هذا التوجه وهل ستكون اوكرانيا
قادره على الحد من عسكره روسيا للبحر
الاسود هذا امر لا يسعني سوى التخمين
بشانه وربما لم يتخذ بعد قرار حول ذلك
سنراقب الوضع في الاسابيع والشهور المقبله
فيما يخص الصراع البحري بين روسيا
واوكرانيا علاوه على البحث عن اي تدابير
ردع محتمله في البحر الاسود قد يقررها
الناتو في الشهور والسنوات المقبله
في ما يتعلق بهذه التطورات هل تعتقد بان
نيته يعني هل تعتقد ان حلف الناتو ليس
لديه القوات البحريه الكافيه لفرد السيطره
على يعني المنطقه التي يريد ان يفرض
السيطره عليها ام انه ال- ال- حلف النيته
ليس لديه الرغبه لا توجد قوات ام انه لا
توجد رغبه
هذا سؤال مهم للغايه واشكرك على طرحه
فللسنوات طويله عندما عملت في الناتو
مستشاره للرئيس الروماني السابق ركزت على
منطقه البحر الاسود لفتره طويله من الزمن
هناك حضور قوي للحلف من خلال نشر اسطولا
للنيتو في البحر الاسود وحتى هذا العام
وبما في ذلك التدابير التي اتخذت قرارات
بشانها في قمه حلف الناتو في مدريد هذا
العام لم ارى الحلف يكثف نشاطه في هذا
المجال وقد يعود السبب لعدم توفر الاراده
السياسيه اضافه الى التكلفه الماليه لخطوه
كهذه» مع العلم ان اجراء كهذا يتطلب
تنسيقا مع دول الحلف المطله على البحر
الاسود لا سيما بولغاريا وتركيا منذ عام
2016 اقترحت رومانيا ان شاء الله للبحر
الاسود واكتشفنا ان ذلك ان تركيا وبوغاريا
معارضه حيل هذه الخطوه خشيه ان تسفر عن
تصعيدا في الوضع والان نرى تحرك تركيا
بشان الحصار البحري
التهديدات تغيرات وقوه روسيا العسكريه تم
سوء تقديرها وبلدان الناتو التي تمتد
سواحلها على البحر الاسود تتاثر اليوم
اكثر فاكثر من عسكره روسيا للبحر الاسود
غير ان ذلك لم يحل المشكله التي تركز
عليها تركيا الا وهي اتفاقيه مونترو التي
تمنحها الحق في اتخاذ القرار بشان الوجود
العسكري الاجنبي في مضيقي البسفور
والدردنيل حتى تتمكن قوه الناتو من الوصول
الى البحر الاسود ولا يوجد حاليا مفاوضات
او حلول وسط في الناتو حول انشاء قوه
في البحر الاسود بدعم تركي انها مشكله
قائمه امل وانه في الشهور والسنوات
المقبله سينصب تركيزه حلف الناتو منظمه
عليها للتواصل الى حل حول منحي حريه
الملاحه للبلدان المطله على البحر الاسود
التي هي اعضاء
وتتاثر بالوضع مثل جورجيا واوكرانيا ومن
اجل الحد من عسكره البحر الاسود بسبب
روسيا
السابقه
دراسات الامنيه في جامعه جورج تاون في
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا